T-15 seconds. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantantham. On January 28, 1986, the Challenger spacecraft blasted off from Cape Canaveral in Florida. One and liftoff, liftoff of the 25th Space Shuttle mission and it has cleared the tower. Seconds after liftoff into a clear blue sky. Something went wrong. Like a troller's here looking very carefully at the situation. Obviously a major malfunction. It was much more than a malfunction. It was a disaster. As millions of people watched in horror, trails of smoke and debris flew off in different directions.
倒计时15秒。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。1986年1月28日，“挑战者号”航天飞机从佛罗里达州的卡纳维拉尔角发射升空。发射，第25次航天飞机任务发射升空，它已经飞离发射塔。在升空进入晴朗蓝天后的几秒钟内，出事了。就像拖网渔船在这里非常仔细地观察局势一样。显然发生了重大故障。这不仅仅是故障，而是一场灾难。当数百万人惊恐地注视着时，烟雾和碎片向四面八方飞散。
We have a report from the flight dynamics officer that the vehicle has exploded. What appears to be a major catastrophe in America's space program, Challenger only seconds after leaving the launch pad, according to NASA, has exploded in mid-air. exploded in mid-air. After the explosion, NASA officials were hauled to Capitol Hill and put to questioning. Who finally made that decision to go? What was the chain? How did that link? What happened then specifically?
我们收到飞行动力官员的报告，称航天飞机已经爆炸。据美国国家航空航天局（NASA）称，这似乎是美国航天计划的一场重大灾难，“挑战者号”在离开发射台仅几秒钟后就在半空中爆炸了。在半空中爆炸。爆炸发生后，NASA官员被传唤到国会山接受质询。到底是谁做出了发射的决定？决策链条是什么？环节是如何衔接的？当时具体发生了什么？
Members of Congress asked the tough questions. How could this have happened? Who's to blame? Were they warning signs that were ignored? These are the kinds of questions we have when any catastrophe occurs, whether a spacecraft has exploded or a city's been attacked by terrorists.
国会议员们提出了尖锐的问题。这怎么可能发生？谁该负责？是否有被忽视的预警信号？无论是一艘航天飞机爆炸，还是一个城市遭到恐怖分子袭击，当任何灾难发生时，我们都会产生这类疑问。
In all these cases, we want to know who screwed up. Your government failed you. Those entrusted with protecting you, failed you. And I failed you. We ask, who knew what? When? The State Department had received repeated warnings that the situation was getting worse. I would try to figure out how.
在所有这些案例中，我们都想知道是谁搞砸了。政府辜负了你们。那些受托保护你们的人辜负了你们。我也辜负了你们。我们问，谁知道什么？什么时候知道的？国务院曾多次收到警告，称局势正在恶化。我会试着弄清楚原因。
How do we make sure that this kind of breach? That such an accident does not ever happen again. With many of these incidents, there's a sense that they could have been avoided, that someone knew something but didn't say anything. Or if they said it, they weren't believed. Or if they were believed, nothing was done. This week on Hidden Brain, the psychology of warnings, why some warnings get heard, why many are ignored, and the pitfalls of being a prophet. We begin the tale of warnings made and warnings ignored in the middle of Alaska. I'm in a car riding on a weather-beaten road that leads out of Fairbanks.
我们如何确保这种漏洞？确保此类事故不再发生？对于许多此类事件，人们总觉得它们本可以避免，有人知道些什么但没说出来。或者如果他们说了，却没人相信。又或者如果他们被相信了，却什么也没做。本周的《隐藏的大脑》将探讨预警心理学：为什么有些警告会被听取，为什么许多警告被忽视，以及作为先知的陷阱。我们从阿拉斯加中部开始讲述关于警告被发出和被忽视的故事。我正坐在一辆车里，行驶在费尔班克斯外一条饱经风霜的道路上。
Chris Heimstra is driving and he points out something. You can see in the road here, you see all these bumps and all these curves. These aren't your standard potholes. The state of the road is a sign of something far more significant. Beneath the pavement, the ground is disintegrating. What lies below the asphalt is the Alaskan permafrost and it's melting. Permafrost is any soil or ice or rock that's frozen for more than two years, like two consecutive years. Picture the plants and animals that lived in Alaska over the past tens of thousands of years.
克里斯·海姆斯特拉正在开车，他指出了某样东西。你可以看到路上的这些颠簸和弯道。这些不是普通的坑洼。路况是某种更重要事物的迹象。在路面之下，地面正在解体。沥青下面是阿拉斯加的永久冻土，而且它正在融化。永久冻土是指任何冻结超过两年，比如连续两年冻结的土壤、冰或岩石。想象一下过去几万年来生活在阿拉斯加的动植物。
After they died and fell to the ground, they froze. Pomerphrost is made up of layer upon layer of this organic frozen material. There's a place where you can see what's happening deep inside this pomerphrost. It's a tunnel that's hundreds of feet long. It's built into the side of an Alaskan hill. Chris is a research scientist at the Army Corps of Engineers. He works in the cold regions, research, and engineering laboratory out of Fairbanks.
它们死后落到地面，然后冻结。永久冻土是由一层又一层这种有机冻结物质组成的。有一个地方你可以看到这种永久冻土深处正在发生什么。那是一条数百英尺长的隧道。它建在阿拉斯加一座山丘的侧面。克里斯是陆军工程兵团的研究科学家。他在费尔班克斯的寒冷地区研究与工程实验室工作。
He has spent a lot of time in this tunnel, and he's taking me there today to show me something important. There's 40,000 years of earth history that's stored and frozen in time. To get to that frozen history, we walked through a set of gates, over to a wood cabin, a whole bunch of hard hats. We head over to what looks like a nondescript wooden shed. It has a sign on the outside that says US Army Corps of Engineers and a warning to watch
他在这个隧道里花了很多时间，今天他带我来这里是为了向我展示一些重要的东西。这里储存并冻结了4万年的地球历史。为了到达那段冰封的历史，我们穿过一道大门，走到一个木屋前，那里有一堆安全帽。我们走向一个看起来不起眼的木棚。外面有一个牌子，写着“美国陆军工程兵团”，并警告要小心
your step. Inside it's pitch black. At the far end there's another door that leads into the actual tunnel. Chris turns on the lights and leads me through. We walk down to a lower area. The deeper we go, the lower down you go into the tunnel, the older you are in sediment. The further back we move in time. Okay, so like back over here. When Chris describes what's in the tunnel, he's even toned. But what I can see all around me is completely extraordinary.
脚下。里面漆黑一片。在尽头有另一扇门，通向真正的隧道。克里斯打开灯，带我穿过。我们走到一个较低的区域。我们走得越深，进入隧道越低，沉积物就越古老。我们在时间上回溯得越远。好吧，就像回到这里。当克里斯描述隧道里的东西时，他的语气很平稳。但我周围所能看到的一切都非常非凡。
So on that, that's like a 43,000 year old piece of probably willow. It's been sitting down here for quite a while. 43,000 years old. It actually looks like it could have fallen last year. Yeah it's amazing. The cold temperatures and how long it can be organic matter can be preserved here. If you're picturing this like a real life trip on the Magic School bus, you're right. Except there's one part of the experience that doesn't exactly fill me with wonder. Like the aromas, one thing that people notice right away. I was just going to ask you, is it just me or is this place ting? It's suddenly got it, an unusual smell, and that's your organic matter that's coming back into the atmosphere.
所以那个，那是一块大约4.3万年前的柳树木头。它在这里已经放了很久了。4.3万年前。它看起来就像是去年才掉落的。是的，这太神奇了。寒冷的温度以及有机物质在这里能保存多久。如果你把这想象成现实生活中的《神奇校车》之旅，你是对的。除了体验中有一个部分并不能让我感到惊奇。比如气味，这是人们立刻会注意到的事情。我正要问你，是只有我这么觉得，还是这个地方有味道？它突然有了一种不寻常的气味，那是你的有机物质正在回到大气中。
All around me, the decaying plants and animals smell like food gone bad in a freezer. The smell is unpleasant, but what it ought to be, is terrifying. Something is happening here that has consequences for the entire planet. The organic matter trapped in the permafrost, fungi, plants, animals, it's thawing. As a thaw, it decays. And as it decays, it releases extraordinary amounts of carbon into the atmosphere. How much carbon? Scientists say the amount of carbon that's stored in the permafrost is about double of what's in the entire atmosphere. Let me say it again. Double. It's in the deep
在我周围，腐烂的动植物闻起来就像冰箱里变质的食物。这种气味令人不快，但它本该是令人恐惧的。这里正在发生的事情对整个地球都有影响。困在永久冻土中的有机物质，真菌、植物、动物，正在解冻。随着解冻，它们开始腐烂。而随着腐烂，它们向大气中释放出惊人的碳含量。有多少碳？科学家说，永久冻土中储存的碳量大约是整个大气中碳含量的两倍。让我再说一遍。两倍。它处于深层
freeze. What happens if that temperature goes up, or for some reason it thaws a little bit more? What happens if that carbon, a place you don't necessarily want it, is back in the atmosphere. We don't want it back in the atmosphere, because carbon dioxide contributes to climate change. But a vicious cycle has already started. As the planet warms, the making its way around the globe. The burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning and the burning in area as large as West Virginia, and the smoke from those fires is making its way around the globe.
冷冻状态。如果温度升高，或者由于某种原因它融化得更多，会发生什么？如果那些碳，那些你并不一定想要的地方，回到了大气中会怎样？我们不希望它回到大气中，因为二氧化碳会导致气候变化。但一个恶性循环已经开始了。随着地球变暖，它正在全球范围内蔓延。燃烧、燃烧、燃烧……在西弗吉尼亚州那么大的区域内，这些火灾产生的烟雾正在全球范围内蔓延。
It's raining and no big deal, and then we see the water going down the street start to get a little bit higher until it's up to the curb of the sidewalk. Oh my God! Man, let's go in on it! At the rate, global temperatures are rising 60% of all the glaciers here in Xinjiang, nearly 11,000 glaciers will be gone within 50 years. Chris doesn't need to turn on the news to see what rising temperatures are doing to the planet.
下着雨，没什么大不了的，然后我们看到街上的水开始变高，直到漫过人行道的路缘。天哪！伙计，我们进去看看！按照全球气温上升的速度，新疆60%的冰川，近1.1万座冰川将在50年内消失。克里斯不需要打开新闻就能看到气温上升对地球的影响。
When he's in the tunnel, he can see it right in front of his eyes. He can smell it. He's reminded of it every time he drives on the cracked pavement. And there's a feeling that he can't escape. It comes when he's at time he drives on the cracked pavement. And there's a feeling that he can't escape. It comes when he's at work, when he talks to strangers, even when he's in the comfort of his own car. That feeling is futility. He can see a catastrophe unfolding in front of him, but no one seems to be listening. Or people seem to be worried about the wrong things, like in a conversation
当他在隧道里时，他能亲眼看到。他能闻到。每次他开车经过破裂的路面时，他都会想起这一点。有一种他无法逃避的感觉。这种感觉在他工作时、与陌生人交谈时，甚至在他坐在自己舒适的车里时都会出现。那种感觉是徒劳。他能看到一场灾难在他面前展开，但似乎没有人听。或者人们似乎在担心错误的事情，比如在一次谈话中
he had earlier in the day. The claim was made that most of the CO2 in the atmosphere comes from volcanoes, which isn't the case. Who made the claim? It was somebody on the school field trip earlier today. And I pushed back against that politely. And it's hard because you've got to be really, it's so hard to be, you don't want to offend people, you don't want to, because making someone angry isn't going to change their mind at all.
他今天早些时候进行的谈话。有人声称大气中大部分二氧化碳来自火山，事实并非如此。是谁提出的这个说法？是今天早些时候学校实地考察时的一个人。我礼貌地反驳了这一点。这很难，因为你必须非常……很难做到，你不想冒犯别人，你不想，因为让别人生气根本改变不了他们的想法。
So you've got to be really careful about how you wait into things and you don't know this person necessarily and there's not a familial tie. So it's a stranger, someone who's all we have really in common is that our kids go to the same school and they're in the same class. But it was a crucial piece of misinformation that wasn't true. And then you just say like flat out like that's not true. I mean that's going to shut everything down and it's not going to help me in any way. It's just going to make somebody who thinks I'm a jerk. To Chris, it seems as if the pushback he gets is driven by a logic contempt that some people feel towards science and scientists. It's not relegated or limited to your work. It's a critique of you as a person, as if you're just trying to lie to people about the work you do,
所以你必须非常小心你如何介入事情，你不一定认识这个人，而且没有亲属关系。所以这是一个陌生人，我们唯一共同点就是我们的孩子在同一所学校，在同一个班级。但这是一个关键的错误信息，不是事实。然后你只是直截了当地说那不是真的。我的意思是，那会把一切都搞砸，对我没有任何帮助。只会让别人觉得我是个混蛋。对克里斯来说，他得到的反击似乎是由某些人对科学和科学家的逻辑蔑视所驱动的。这不仅仅是针对你的工作。这是对你个人的批评，就好像你只是试图在你的工作上对人们撒谎，
which doesn't make any sense. Your stock as a scientist is because you're honesty. If you're not honest as a scientist, your career is over. And it should be over. Chris feels invisible. He walks in a remote place 40 feet below the surface in a part of the country that's unfamiliar to most Americans. A lot of them will never make it up here.
这根本说不通。你作为科学家的信誉是因为你的诚实。如果你作为科学家不诚实，你的职业生涯就结束了。而且它确实应该结束。克里斯感到被忽视了。他在一个偏远的地方行走，在地下40英尺处，在这个国家的大部分美国人都不熟悉的地方。他们中的许多人永远不会到这里来。
A lot of them won't go into the Permphrost tunnel. A lot of them won't go run up above the tunnel or throughout Alaska where Permphrost exists or even understand what it looks like, what it smells like. So how do you communicate that? How do you say like there's a value in you understanding what you don't currently understand? How do you get people to see that there's value in understanding what they don't understand? Chris's question is an ancient question. For millennia, we often shunned and shamed people who have warned us of looming disaster.
他们中的许多人不会进入永久冻土隧道。他们中的许多人不会去永久冻土存在的隧道上方或整个阿拉斯加，甚至不了解它看起来是什么样，闻起来是什么样。那么你如何沟通呢？你如何说，理解你目前不理解的东西是有价值的？你如何让人们看到理解他们不理解的东西是有价值的？克里斯的问题是一个古老的问题。几千年来，我们经常回避和羞辱那些警告我们灾难即将来临的人。
Why does this happen? Why do human beings who care about their survival ignore warnings of doom? When we come back, we're going to do something unusual. We're going to look for answers to that question, not in science, but in literature. We're going to dive into Greek mythology and talk about a doomed prophet. The lessons from her story still resonate today. In Greek mythology, the gods loom large. So large that many of them fill our imaginations even today. Zeus, with his thunderbolts, Aphrodite, the goddess of love, Hades, in charge of the underworld, Athena, goddess of wisdom. The gods of ancient Greece moved among humans. Some of those humans
为什么会这样？为什么关心自己生存的人类会忽视末日警告？当我们回来时，我们将做一些不寻常的事情。我们将寻找这个问题的答案，不是在科学中，而是在文学中。我们将深入希腊神话，谈论一位注定失败的先知。她故事中的教训在今天仍然引起共鸣。在希腊神话中，众神高高在上。如此之大，以至于即使在今天，他们中的许多人仍然充斥着我们的想象力。宙斯，带着他的雷霆；阿佛洛狄忒，爱之女神；哈迪斯，掌管冥界；雅典娜，智慧女神。古希腊的众神在人类中穿行。其中一些人类
were themselves touched with divine powers. One of the most striking was the prophet Cassandra. Cassandra remained so memorable that her story has inspired movies, television, even campy pop music. In 1982, the Swedish band Abba dedicated a song to her more than 2,500 years after she was first memorialized by Homer, Eskilis, and Euripides. This power that Cassandra had was incredible. Except there was one problem. No one believed her.
本身就被赋予了神力。最引人注目的是先知卡珊德拉。卡珊德拉令人难忘，以至于她的故事激发了电影、电视，甚至是俗气的流行音乐。1982年，瑞典乐队ABBA为她创作了一首歌，距离她最初被荷马、埃斯库罗斯和欧里庇得斯纪念已经过去了2500多年。卡珊德拉拥有的这种力量是不可思议的。除了有一个问题。没有人相信她。
It's not Cassandra's fault that she's not believed. This is Emily Wilson. I'm a professor of classical studies at the University of Pennsylvania. Emily is going to take us back to the legend of the Kingdom of Troy. She's going to help us understand what this ancient myth still has to teach us. Cassandra's father, Priam, was the King of Troy. It's safe to say that Cassandra didn't suffer from only child syndrome. Priam has, according to different accounts, either 50 or 100 children. She's one of the many children of Priya. Cassandra has a blessing that is really a curse. She can see the future, but no one will
不被相信并不是卡珊德拉的错。这是艾米丽·威尔逊。我是宾夕法尼亚大学古典研究教授。艾米丽将带我们回到特洛伊王国的传说。她将帮助我们理解这个古老的神话今天还能教给我们什么。卡珊德拉的父亲普里阿摩斯是特洛伊国王。可以肯定地说，卡珊德拉并没有患上独生子女综合症。根据不同的记载，普里阿摩斯有50或100个孩子。她是普里阿摩斯的众多孩子之一。卡珊德拉有一个祝福，实际上是一个诅咒。她能看到未来，但没有人会
believe her. But even if you set aside the curse, it turns out she also did several things that made it less likely she would be believed. For one thing, her prophecies were a pick. When she revealed her visions, she spoke in language that was a little hard to understand. What's this in front of my eyes now? Is it a hunting net out of the underworld? Yes, but a man trapped too, that sleeps with him, helps plot his murder,
相信她。但即使你抛开诅咒，事实证明她也做了几件事，使她更不可能被相信。首先，她的预言是隐晦的。当她揭示她的愿景时，她使用的语言有点难以理解。现在在我眼前的是什么？是来自冥界的狩猎网吗？是的，还有一个被困住的男人，和她一起睡觉，帮助策划谋杀，
let the mob endlessly gorging on this clan, raise a shriek over the sacrifice on which stones will fall in their turn. She speaks primarily in symbols and metaphors that she can foresee the the ox killed at the altar. She can foresee blood and slaughter. She doesn't speak in a way that sort of spells out exactly as soon as I walk into this house, Clyton Nesteros is going to take the axe and hack us both to death. Because that's not the way Oracle speaks. She speaks in prophetic language. Cassandra's best known prophecy had to do with one of the world's most famous carpentry
让那群人无休止地在这个氏族身上饕餮，为牺牲发出尖叫，石头也会轮流落下。她主要用符号和隐喻说话，她能预见祭坛上被杀的牛。她能预见鲜血和屠杀。她说话的方式并不是那种明确拼写出来，比如“我一走进这所房子，克吕泰涅斯特拉就会拿起斧头把我们俩都砍死”。因为神谕不是那样说话的。她用预言的语言说话。卡珊德拉最著名的预言与世界上最著名的木工项目之一有关，
projects, the Trojan horse. There's a war between the Trojans and the Greeks and it's dragging on. It keeps going for 10 years without decisive victory on either side. The turning point comes when the Greeks have an idea. That they should build a great big wooden horse and have their best warriors on the Greek side hide inside the wooden horse. They leave the great big wooden horse outside the walls of Troy. As the Trojan's watch from their city, the Greeks get in their ships, seemingly in defeat,
特洛伊木马。特洛伊人和希腊人之间有一场战争，而且拖延了很久。它持续了10年，双方都没有决定性的胜利。转折点出现在希腊人有一个主意的时候。他们应该建造一匹巨大的木马，让希腊方面最优秀的战士藏在木马里。他们把那匹巨大的木马留在特洛伊城墙外。当特洛伊人从城里观看时，希腊人登上他们的船，似乎战败了，
and sail away. Their mysterious gift remains on the beach, and the Trojan's debate, whether to throw open the city gates and bring in the horse. Is this some kind of gift for the gods? Is it a holy offering? Should be mistrusted, should be not mistrusted. Cassandra knows that this gift is not a gift at all. She tells her fellow citizens not to open the
然后航行离开。他们神秘的礼物留在海滩上，特洛伊人争论是否要打开城门把马带进来。这是给神的某种礼物吗？这是神圣的祭品吗？应该不信任，还是不应该不信任？卡珊德拉知道这份礼物根本不是礼物。她告诉她的同胞不要打开
gates of Troy. In her own convoluted way she says, this is a terrible idea, don't do it. But she doesn't have any real power. Her fellow children don't recognize her as a prophet, but she doesn't have any real power. Her fellow childrens don't recognize her as a prophet, and so she's not taken seriously. The consequences are disastrous. The Trojans decide in the end to bring the horse in, and then, of course, in the middle of the night, the Greek warriors spring out of the horse
特洛伊的城门。她用自己复杂的方式说，这是一个可怕的主意，不要这样做。但她没有任何真正的权力。她的同胞并不认为她是先知，所以她没有被认真对待。后果是灾难性的。特洛伊人最终决定把马带进来，然后，当然，在深夜，希腊战士从马里跳出来，
and start slaughtering the citizens inside the city. You think that after Cassandra accurately predicts the fall of Troy, some people might start believing her. You'd be wrong. She makes another prediction that fails to gain any traction. As the city is burning and the women of Troy are forced to board Greek ships as slaves, all the prisoners are distraught, all except Cassandra, who seems weirdly happy. Her mother seems deeply concerned about her worried for her as one would be for a daughter who keeps saying crazy stuff, and who also seems to have this perverse idea that being taken into slavery could be a good thing. There's a reason why Cassandra has this oddly positive reaction.
开始屠杀城里的公民。你以为在卡珊德拉准确预测特洛伊陷落后，有些人可能会开始相信她。你错了。她又做了一个预测，但未能获得任何支持。当城市在燃烧，特洛伊妇女被迫作为奴隶登上希腊船只时，所有的囚犯都心烦意乱，除了卡珊德拉，她看起来异常高兴。她的母亲似乎对她深感担忧，为一个不断说疯话的女儿担心，而且她似乎还有一种变态的想法，认为被带走做奴隶可能是一件好事。卡珊德拉有这种奇怪的积极反应是有原因的。
Whereas everyone else can only see what's right in front of them, she can see two steps ahead. She already knows something about her situation. She knows she's going to die, but so is her captor, the Greek general Agamemnon. Revenge is coming, even if it means her own death. Cassandra sees a gleam of hope in the fact that she knows Agamemnon's going to be murdered horribly. She can see that there's going to be bad things for the Greeks down the line. So to recap, there are several things besides the curse that make Cassandra
当其他人只能看到眼前的东西时，她能看到两步之外。她已经知道关于她处境的一些事情。她知道她会死，但她的俘虏，希腊将军阿伽门农也会死。复仇即将来临，即使这意味着她自己的死亡。卡珊德拉在知道阿伽门农会被残忍谋杀的事实中看到了一线希望。她能看到希腊人未来会有坏事发生。所以总结一下，除了诅咒之外，还有几件事使卡珊德拉
less likely to be believed. She speaks in cryptic language. She doesn't have any formal authority. She's too far ahead of everyone else. There's one more thing, she asks too much of the people she warns. This happens when Agamemnon takes Cassandra back to Greece with him as a slave. They go to his home. Agamemnon doesn't know that during his absence, his wife Clytemnestra has started an affair. He doesn't know that Clytemnestra is not pleased to have him back, but she pretends to be happy. So she welcomes him into the house, along with Cassandra, as his human property.
更不可能被相信。她用隐晦的语言说话。她没有任何正式的权威。她比其他人领先太多。还有一件事，她对她警告的人要求太多。这发生在阿伽门农把卡珊德拉作为奴隶带回希腊时。他们去了他的家。阿伽门农不知道在他离开期间，他的妻子克吕泰涅斯特拉已经开始了一段婚外情。他不知道克吕泰涅斯特拉并不高兴他回来，但她假装很高兴。所以她欢迎他进屋，连同作为他私人财产的卡珊德拉。
He goes first into the house, and then Cassandra pauses to give these prophecies, these riddling prophecies. Cassandra foresees his death, and her own. Look at this! Look! Keep the bull away from the heifer! She's caught him in her dress! sees his death at her own. It's late and wait for him, I tell you. Or, to translate, Klaikdomnestry is about to hack her husband to death with an axe. For Agamemnon to take a Sandra seriously, he would have to see that his life was in danger,
他先走进屋子，然后卡珊德拉停下来发表这些预言，这些谜语般的预言。卡珊德拉预见了他们的死亡，以及她自己的死亡。看这个！看！让公牛远离小母牛！她用裙子抓住了他！预见了他的死亡和她自己的死亡。天晚了，等着他，我告诉你。或者，翻译过来就是，克吕泰涅斯特拉正要用斧头把她的丈夫砍死。为了让阿伽门农认真对待卡珊德拉，他必须看到他的生命处于危险之中，
that his wife despised him. That far from being a victorious warrior, he was walking into a death trap. To save his own life, he would have to change his entire outlook. He wants to think of himself as a strong triumphant city-saccer, and he's only going to process the information that confirms that belief about himself. And he's going to ignore all the signs both from Clayton Nester
他的妻子鄙视他。他不仅不是一个胜利的战士，而且正走进一个死亡陷阱。为了挽救自己的生命，他必须改变他整个观点。他想把自己看作一个强大的、胜利的城市征服者，他只会处理那些证实他对自己这种信念的信息。他会忽略所有来自克吕泰涅斯特拉
and from Cassandra that might suggest that reality is not the only reality, and in fact fact you're missing a whole lot of information here. Things play out just as Cassandra predicted. She's caught him in her dress, her engine, on her black horn, striking! Clyde and Nesterah give Simma lovely bath and she entrap Simma in a net as well in order to make sure that if he struggles after the first blow he won't get away So she strikes him multiple times till he's good and dead and also hats Cassandra to death The soundtrack it was a particularly gruesome murder, but maybe I'm wrong
和卡珊德拉的迹象，这些迹象可能暗示现实不仅仅是那个现实，事实上你在这里错过了很多信息。事情的发展正如卡珊德拉所预言的那样。她用裙子抓住了他，她的引擎，在她的黑角上，打击！克吕泰涅斯特拉给了他一个可爱的洗澡，她也把他困在网里，以确保如果他在第一击后挣扎，他就逃不掉。所以她多次打击他，直到他死透，也把卡珊德拉砍死了。配乐，这是一场特别可怕的谋杀，但也许我错了。
Maybe this is part for the course in Athenian tragedy. I think it's part for the course I mean it's much less gruesome than the death of Pentheus That was usually some gory death. Yeah. Why else would you go to the theatre? Now of course, Cassandra was cursed. By definition, it didn't matter how persuasive she was. She was never going to be believed. But her failed attempts to warn those around her can give us insights into how warnings are heard, whether they take it seriously, and when they're acted upon.
也许这是雅典悲剧的常态。我认为这是常态，我的意思是它比彭透斯的死要少得多。那通常是一些血腥的死亡。是的。不然你为什么要去看戏呢？当然，卡珊德拉被诅咒了。根据定义，她有多有说服力并不重要。她永远不会被相信。但她警告周围人的失败尝试可以让我们深入了解警告是如何被听到的，他们是否认真对待，以及何时采取行动。
When we come back, how can real life Cassandra's undo the curse and actually be believed? This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is what a Cassandra who's effective sounds like. I speak loudly all the time, because I'm kind of aggressive person, you know, even though I'm all, I'll be 70 next year. My wife said, will you please calm down? She's been saying it for 43 years now and it hasn't happened. The actual name of this Cassandra is Andrew Natios.
当我们回来时，现实生活中的卡珊德拉如何打破诅咒并真正被相信？这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这就是一个有效的卡珊德拉听起来的样子。我一直大声说话，因为我是一个有点咄咄逼人的人，你知道，尽管我明年就70岁了。我妻子说，你能不能冷静点？她已经说了43年了，但这并没有发生。这个卡珊德拉的真实名字是安德鲁·纳齐奥斯。
His moment of prophecy involved a life and death choice that affected hundreds of thousands of people. Before we get to that, we need to understand the formative moments in Andrew's career. In many ways, he was an unlikely hero. In the 1980s, he served in the Massachusetts House of Representatives. At a Republican National Committee meeting in 1988, he didn't exactly get the star treatment. Chair recognizes Nassio from Maryland.
他的预言时刻涉及到一个影响数十万人的生死抉择。在我们谈到这一点之前，我们需要了解安德鲁职业生涯中的形成性时刻。在许多方面，他是一个不太可能的英雄。在20世纪80年代，他在马萨诸塞州众议院任职。在1988年的一次共和党全国委员会会议上，他并没有得到明星待遇。主席认可来自马里兰州的纳齐奥斯。
Nassio's from Massachusetts. Nassio's, I'm quarantined here, sorry. Before he got to Esquisandra moment, Andrew was brought into salvage a boondoggle of a transportation project in Boston, the big dig. It redirected a massive highway into a tunnel under the city. Andrew came in several years into the project. At that point, it was a mess with huge cost overruns.
纳齐奥斯来自马萨诸塞州。纳齐奥斯，我被隔离在这里，抱歉。在他达到埃斯库罗斯式的卡珊德拉时刻之前，安德鲁被请来挽救波士顿一个交通项目的烂摊子，即“大挖掘”。它将一条巨大的高速公路改道进入城市下方的一条隧道。安德鲁在项目进行了几年后加入。那时，它是一团糟，成本严重超支。
Andrew had two things going for him. He had experienced leading big institutions, and he had his temperament. I'm sort of a type A personality very kind of aggressive and a dominant figure in any institution that I run. So I could get the institution to do what I wanted it to do, what I thought was right to do. He was in fact able to figure out why the project's finances were out of whack. But his efforts weren't always appreciated. It was the most difficult year of my career. Actually, I actually felt safer in Sudan and Iraq and Afghanistan that I did in Boston.
安德鲁有两个优势。他有领导大型机构的经验，而且他有他的脾气。我是一个A型人格，非常咄咄逼人，在我经营的任何机构中都是主导人物。所以我能让机构做我想做的事，我认为正确的事。事实上，他能够弄清楚为什么项目的财务状况失控。但他的努力并不总是受到赞赏。这是我职业生涯中最困难的一年。实际上，我在苏丹、伊拉克和阿富汗比在波士顿感觉更安全。
One person threatened to break my neck while I was investigating the big dig. And I was threatened once I took over too, so I wanted to threaten to kill me then too. Andrew had spent much of his career overseas. His experience leading several national and international organizations, Cothea of President George W. Bush, who appointed him to lead USAID. That's the agency responsible for America's involvement in international development. It's here that Andrew had his prophetic moment. In 2003, Andrew briefed top members of the Bush administration about escalating violence in Sudan.
当我在调查“大挖掘”时，有人威胁要打断我的脖子。我接手后也受到了威胁，所以他们当时也威胁要杀我。安德鲁职业生涯的大部分时间都在海外度过。他领导多个国家和国际组织的经验，乔治·W·布什总统任命他领导美国国际开发署（USAID）。那是负责美国参与国际发展的机构。正是在这里，安德鲁有了他的预言时刻。2003年，安德鲁向布什政府的高层成员简要介绍了苏丹不断升级的暴力事件。
By that point, marauders were charging into villages, setting them on fire, sending civilians fleeing. They were known as a january. They quickly took over a vast and dusty region on the edge of the Sahara. Darfur. Andrew's warnings and advice had an impact. The US supplied billions of dollars in aid to Sudan over the next several years. Inspired the economic difficulties, our aid will continue to flow.
到那时，掠夺者正冲进村庄，放火焚烧，导致平民逃离。他们被称为“金戈威德”。他们迅速占领了撒哈拉边缘一个广阔而尘土飞扬的地区。达尔富尔。安德鲁的警告和建议产生了影响。美国在接下来的几年里向苏丹提供了数十亿美元的援助。尽管经济困难，我们的援助将继续流动。
President Bush also put political pressure on Sudanese leaders. Some of his measures were behind the scenes, others more public. The news media began to take note. Today President Bush announced tough new economic sanctions against Sudan over the continued persecution of the minority population in Darfur. Andrews actions at USAID have become a case study on effective warnings. That's according to Christoph Mayer. I'm a professor of European and international politics at Kings College, London.
布什总统也对苏丹领导人施加了政治压力。他的一些措施是在幕后的，另一些则更公开。新闻媒体开始注意到。今天，布什总统宣布对苏丹实施新的严厉经济制裁，原因是其继续迫害达尔富尔的少数民族人口。安德鲁在USAID的行动已成为有效警告的案例研究。这是克里斯托弗·迈耶的观点。我是伦敦国王学院欧洲和国际政治教授。
Christoph has spent many years studying how warnings are made and which ones manage to break through the noise. He says there are several reasons Andrew Nio's managed to persuade the Bush administration to act. One is he was able to show how further escalation with many hundreds of thousands of people that was highly likely and he was able to kind of put that into a presentation, you know, chart the escalation of the conflict into the future.
克里斯托弗花了很多年研究警告是如何发出的，以及哪些警告成功突破了噪音。他说安德鲁·纳齐奥斯成功说服布什政府采取行动有几个原因。一是由于他能够展示进一步升级将导致数十万人受害的可能性极高，并且他能够将其放入演示文稿中，你知道，绘制冲突未来升级的图表。
Andrew commissioned a study that predicted how many people would die if the US didn't intervene. He also got US spy satellites to take pictures of Darfur. To photograph the ground every day to show the villages that were being burned from day to day. And these photographs were so clear that the photographs were unimpeachable in terms of their quality, in terms of what the atrocities were. And they burned 30 at 100 villages.
安德鲁委托进行了一项研究，预测如果美国不干预，会有多少人死亡。他还让美国间谍卫星拍摄达尔富尔的照片。每天拍摄地面，以显示村庄每天被烧毁的情况。这些照片非常清晰，以至于照片在质量方面、在暴行方面是无可辩驳的。他们烧毁了30到100个村庄。
They displaced two million people. So Andrew laid out clear evidence. There was something else that helped him make the case to the president. He was an insider. Was I taken seriously? Yes, because I had a relationship with the president's. That's presidents plural. He had campaigned twice for George H. W. Bush and he had worked on the George W. Bush campaign in 2000. He was not seen as one of these, you know, do good as one of these kind of liberal NGO types.
他们导致200万人流离失所。所以安德鲁提出了明确的证据。还有其他事情帮助他向总统陈述了理由。他是内部人士。我被认真对待了吗？是的，因为我和总统有关系。那是复数形式的总统。他曾两次为乔治·H·W·布什竞选，并在2000年为乔治·W·布什的竞选工作过。他没有被视为那些，你知道，做好事的人，那些自由派非政府组织类型的人。
Yes, he had a history in the NGO sector. He was an expert, but he was had also a kind of a conservative pedigree. He had had experience in the armed forces. He was seen as someone who understood that the president's time was precious and understood the preferences and he was seen as kind of part of us. And therefore, if someone who was seen as a kind of someone who is kind of almost a national security type, if someone like that would warn about the consequences of that kind of conflict in that country, he would be taken so much more seriously than someone who is seen in a very different light.
是的，他在非政府组织领域有历史。他是专家，但也有某种保守的血统。他在武装部队中有过经验。他被视为一个了解总统时间宝贵并了解偏好的人，他被视为我们的一员。因此，如果一个被视为某种国家安全类型的人，如果像这样的人警告那种国家那种冲突的后果，他会比一个在完全不同光线下被看待的人受到更认真的对待。
Besides his political credentials, Andrew was also an insider in another way. He was a Christian who'd spent years leading an international Christian NGO. He knew that George W. Bush's identity as a Christian was important to him and important to his re-election chances in 2004. Christoph Mayer says Andrew laid out the political consequences of inaction in Darfur, where many of the civilians being attacked were Christian. He was able then to show how that kind of escalation would be politically relevant to the Bush administration at the time, how it would impact on the re-election chances, and how it would
除了他的政治资历，安德鲁在另一方面也是内部人士。他是一名基督徒，曾花多年时间领导一个国际基督教非政府组织。他知道乔治·W·布什作为基督徒的身份对他很重要，对他2004年的连任机会也很重要。克里斯托弗·迈耶说，安德鲁阐述了在达尔富尔不采取行动的政治后果，那里许多受到攻击的平民是基督徒。他能够展示这种升级将如何与当时的布什政府在政治上相关，它将如何影响连任机会，以及它将如何
connect to Christian constituency in the US, which of course are one of the supporting constituencies of the Bush administration, because it was also Christians who were in Sudan, were largely affected by this violence. Andrew implicitly understood a widespread psychological bias. We all tend to look more sympathetically at suffering when the people who are suffering have something in common with us. There's another part to this. Andrew was successful because he did not present in Bush to make a major U-turn. From the very beginning of his administration, the president had been interested in what was happening
与美国的基督教选民联系起来，他们当然是布什政府的支持选民之一，因为在苏丹受到这种暴力影响的主要是基督徒。安德鲁隐含地理解了一种普遍的心理偏见。当受苦的人与我们有共同点时，我们都倾向于更同情他们的苦难。这还有另一部分。安德鲁之所以成功，是因为他没有要求布什做出重大的U型转弯。从他政府的最初开始，总统就一直对苏丹正在发生的事情感兴趣。
and so done. The first presidential review that the president ordered was on Sudan policy. Now, what came to be known as a genocide in Darfur did claim hundreds of thousands of lives. So it may be hard to see Andrew's warning as effective. And yet, if Andrew had not acted, Christophe says he believes things would have turned out worse. I think the Bush administration did act, it did act very early, but it did act politically to put pressure on the conflict parties.
总统下令进行的第一次总统审查就是关于苏丹政策的。现在，后来被称为达尔富尔种族灭绝的事件确实夺去了数十万人的生命。所以可能很难看到安德鲁的警告是有效的。然而，如果安德鲁没有采取行动，克里斯托弗说他相信事情会变得更糟。我认为布什政府确实采取了行动，它确实行动得很早，但它在政治上采取了行动，对冲突各方施加压力。
And they did act, I think, as soon as could be probably expected on the humanitarian front, therefore saving lives through humanitarian action. I couldn't have done that alone, but President Bush did it. And I have to say, I said in my book, I think he ended what could have been another Rwanda genocide. He ended what could have been another Rwanda genocide. So in Andrew Natzios, we have a plain spoken leader. He had the insider credentials to get others on board, and he didn't ask policy makers to do something that was greatly at odds with what they wanted to do anyway. Contrast that with the doomed prophet we heard about earlier.
而且我认为，他们在人道主义方面确实采取了尽可能预期的行动，从而通过人道主义行动挽救了生命。我不可能独自做到这一点，但布什总统做到了。我必须说，我在书中说过，我认为他结束了可能成为又一场卢旺达种族灭绝的事件。他结束了可能成为又一场卢旺达种族灭绝的事件。所以，在安德鲁·纳齐奥斯身上，我们看到了一位直言不讳的领导人。他拥有让其他人加入的内部人士资历，而且他没有要求决策者做一些与他们本来想做的事情大相径庭的事情。将此与我们之前听到的注定失败的先知进行对比。
Cassandra spoken riddles. prophetic riddles, but riddles nonetheless. Unlike Andronatios, Cassandra wasn't an insider. As Emily Wilson says, Even if somebody is speaking the truth, if it's coming from the mouth of an unauthoritative person for somebody who's dismissed as other, then that can make it possible to dismiss
卡珊德拉说的是谜语。预言性的谜语，但毕竟是谜语。与安德鲁·纳齐奥斯不同，卡珊德拉不是内部人士。正如艾米丽·威尔逊所说，即使某人说的是真话，如果它来自一个没有权威的人，或者被视为“他者”的人，那么这使得人们有可能忽视
even a very clear articulation of a scary truth. And Cassandra was too far ahead of everyone else. When she and the other children women are being captured as slaves, she doesn't explain that she is happy because she knows the Greeks are going to be killed. She can see into the future, but she doesn't take others along with her. There are lessons here for our own time. Christophe says many modern Cassandra's forget its hard for most people to look far into the future. Leaders especially are often pulled in different directions.
即使是对可怕真相的非常清晰的阐述。而且卡珊德拉比其他人领先太多。当她和其他孩子妇女被俘虏为奴隶时，她没有解释她很高兴，因为她知道希腊人会被杀。她能看到未来，但她没有带上其他人。这对我们这个时代有教训。克里斯托弗说，许多现代卡珊德拉忘记了大多数人很难看得太远。领导者尤其经常被拉向不同的方向。
Paying attention to one risk means fewer resources for others. If you come in with a vague warning about a distant problem, you're going to get sidelined. Samantha Powell wrote in a book, a problem from hell, about the response from one administrator to the warning that was given that unless his telephones were ringing, he couldn't do anything. So even if he believed that what she was saying is right, he was so constrained by the lack of in a sense public clamoring in the beltway that comes support for acting that he couldn't do something. Cassandra also asked the people she was trying to warn to stretch too far outside their comfort zone. Remember what Clitam Nestra is giving Agamemnon a lovely bath? Before she hacks him to death? Cassandra saw it coming.
关注一个风险意味着其他风险的资源减少。如果你带着关于遥远问题的模糊警告进来，你会被边缘化。萨曼莎·鲍尔在一本书《来自地狱的问题》中写道，关于一位行政人员对所给警告的反应，除非他的电话响了，否则他什么也做不了。所以即使他相信她说的是对的，他也受到华盛顿特区缺乏公众呼声的限制，无法采取行动，所以他什么也做不了。卡珊德拉还要求她试图警告的人走出他们的舒适区。还记得克吕泰涅斯特拉给阿伽门农洗澡吗？在她把他砍死之前？卡珊德拉预见到了这一点。
Look at this! Look! Keep the bull away from the heifer! But Agamemnon wasn't in a headspace where he could hear the warning. Christophe says this happens with real-life Cassandra's and real-life policy makers. If leaders have to reject some foundational belief to act on a warning, there's a strong chance that they will simply ignore the warning. Quite often, what makes warnings so difficult to believe is their political inconvenience. In fact, this is exactly what happened in the case of the Challenger Space Shuttle disaster. A scientific inquiry found that several engineers had had concerns about the safety of what came to be known as the O-rings on the shuttle.
看这个！看！让公牛远离小母牛！但阿伽门农当时的心境让他无法听进警告。克里斯托弗说，现实生活中的卡珊德拉和现实生活中的决策者身上也会发生这种情况。如果领导者必须摒弃某种基本信念才能根据警告采取行动，那么他们极有可能直接无视该警告。通常情况下，警告之所以难以置信，是因为它们在政治上不便。事实上，挑战者号航天飞机灾难的情况正是如此。一项科学调查发现，几位工程师曾对后来被称为航天飞机O型环的安全性表示担忧。
They told NASA managers to delay the launch, but the managers overruled the engineers and the challenger took office plan. Like the trollers here looking very carefully at the situation. Obviously a major malfunction. We've painted a picture of warnings that is at odds with the way most of us think about them. In the conventional telling, someone raises an alarm and everyone jumps up and does something about it. In reality, warnings are likely to be heard when they're made by someone who's part of our in-group, when the warning is so imminent that nearly everyone can see the danger, and when the solution doesn't require a radical shift in existing strategy.
他们告诉NASA管理人员推迟发射，但管理人员驳回了工程师的意见，挑战者号按计划升空。就像这里的拖网渔船非常仔细地观察局势一样。显然发生了重大故障。我们描绘的警告画面与我们大多数人的想法不一致。在传统的叙述中，有人发出警报，每个人都会跳起来并采取行动。实际上，只有当警告是由我们内部群体的人发出，当警告迫在眉睫以至于几乎每个人都能看到危险，并且解决方案不需要彻底改变现有策略时，警告才更有可能被听取。
Unsurprisingly, this means that many warnings will go unheeded, and many Cassandra's will be dismissed. In Greek mythology, Cassandra was cursed to be ignored. There really wasn't anything she could do to get people to believe her. For the Cassandra's in our own midst, the curse is even more terrible. Fasettes of the human mind make it difficult for us to pay attention to warnings
不出所料，这意味着许多警告会被忽视，许多卡珊德拉会被解雇。在希腊神话中，卡珊德拉被诅咒永远不被相信。她真的无法做任何事来让人们相信她。对于我们中间的卡珊德拉来说，这种诅咒更加可怕。人类思维的各个方面使我们难以关注警告，
and difficult to act on them until it's nearly too late. How do we make sure that this kind of reach does not never happen again. This week's episode was produced by Reina Cohen and Thomas Liu. He was edited by Tara Boyle and Jenny Schmidt. Our team includes Pat Sha, Laura Corlle and LuShik Waba. Our unsung hero this week is Sophia Dawkins. Sophia has spent years studying the conflict in South Sudan.
并且难以在为时已晚之前采取行动。我们如何确保这种悲剧不再发生？本周的节目由Reina Cohen和Thomas Liu制作。由Tara Boyle和Jenny Schmidt编辑。我们的团队包括Pat Sha、Laura Corlle和LuShik Waba。我们本周的无名英雄是Sophia Dawkins。Sophia多年来一直致力于研究南苏丹的冲突。
She patiently helped us understand the complicated history of the region in order to get the nuances just right. Sometimes, the most important contribution someone can make to a story is to get things out of the story. Thank you, Sophia. You can find more Hidden Brain on Facebook and Twitter. If you like the show, please tell one friend today about our program. I know from both my personal experience and the social science literature that word of
她耐心地帮助我们理解该地区复杂的历史，以便准确把握其中的细微差别。有时，一个人对故事最重要的贡献就是删减故事中的内容。谢谢你，Sophia。你可以在Facebook和Twitter上找到更多关于Hidden Brain的信息。如果你喜欢这个节目，请今天告诉一位朋友。根据我的个人经验和社会科学文献，我知道口碑
math recommendations really matter. If you love Hidden Brain, please spread the word. I'm Shankar Vedantam, and this is NPR. The world is complicated, but knowing the past can help us understand it so much better. That's where we come in. I'm Randabdip Fattah. I'm Ramti N. Arablui, and we're the host of Thru Line, MPR's History Podcast. Every week we'll dig into forgotten stories from the moments that shaped our world. Thru Line, from MPR.
推荐真的很重要。如果你喜欢Hidden Brain，请帮忙宣传。我是Shankar Vedantam，这是NPR。世界很复杂，但了解过去可以帮助我们更好地理解它。这就是我们介入的地方。我是Randabdip Fattah。我是Ramti N. Arablui，我们是NPR历史播客Thru Line的主持人。每周我们都会挖掘塑造我们世界的那些被遗忘的故事。Thru Line，来自NPR。
Listen and subscribe now. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
立即收听并订阅。目前本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。